good morning yeah man whatever you say
dude
whatever you say is what it is I guess
bro dude yeah man if you if you say and
I guess it's good if you say so good if
you say so okay season five episode
eight right
wait a minute
what I haven't even had a sip of coffee
yet and I've been up since
5 15. really why'd you get up so early
um I'm trying so hard to be somebody
that can wake up early and like you know
work out first thing in the morning hmm
I've tried I've done it I've done it for
periods of time before but it's just
it's are you waking up and you're going
straight to work out are you eating
anything are you and you don't have any
coffee before no I go I well so yeah the
alarm goes off at 5 15. I jump out of
bed throw on my gym clothes I go
downstairs I drink basically a giant
glass of water uh and uh take some amino
acids sure right it's a little protein
for the muscles to synthesize while I'm
working out okay and then I go straight
to the gym
yeah but you know are you gonna have any
energy here's the thing that about me
food that stinks about it add more
energy you get older and like everything
gets a little stiffer a little creakier
and it's like boy if if you're doing
that workout at like nine yeah ten
bodies had a chance to warm up yeah
you're feeling I spend the first mobile
I spend the first five minutes on the
treadmill awesome on a steep uphill
climb like walk you know getting getting
the muscles warmed up getting everything
loose and then and that's the beginning
of my warm-up and then I do have like a
whole warm-up routine that I do so I
like warm up for 15-20 minutes before my
workout even starts
wow good and how long is your workout
the workout itself is probably uh 45
minutes that's the 5 15 wake up because
yeah exactly because I'm not I'm not
done till I'm not in the gym until
you know just after 5 30 and then you
know my workout's not really done until
around 6 40. and being honest how long
you think we're going to be keeping up
this this early morning regimen I've
gone through long periods of time long
stretches where I've been good about it
um it's just a matter of like it really
sucks like I'm just I want so
desperately to be one of those people
that can just get seven and a half hours
of sleep it seems like a very reasonable
amount of sleep to get
and I can do it but like really my body
wants nine so I'm forcing myself to just
get seven and a half and uh
I really don't know you know it's just
talking about what your body wants with
such yeah Clarity and earnestness well
because so what I've heard and I don't
know if you guys have heard this but
that our body sleeps in 90 minute Cycles
right so you wanna you wanna be on a 90
minute cycle no matter what it is
whether it's hour six you wake up six
hours of sleep that's 90 minute cycle
seven and a half that's 90 minutes nine
but like anything or not that is not as
good
I don't know man I don't know either I
do find that it's true that around
around six like or in 90 I wake up in 90
minutes Cycles I go back to sleep I'm
trying to take this thing but I I don't
know why this is so funny I don't it's
just it just it's the my peculieness my
particular specificity of it where it's
like you know go to bed wake up don't
worry about it it's like
[Music]
I'm all over the place now
I'm all over the place with your sleep
with everything I I I went uh for a
while without drinking alcohol just to
see how that made me feel same same
thing I thought you I seem to recall you
saying it made you feel worse yeah maybe
worse because you weren't as you weren't
like you weren't experiencing the joy of
having a Manhattan at night that's right
and that was the only difference and as
a result you took one joyful thing away
yeah drinking those those feel free
which I we might have around the office
here
we've got some in the fridge could you
introduce me to something called feel
free which is just an over-the-counter
supplement which I thought was like you
know like an energy drink or something
like that and it turns out it just gets
you high wow it gives you something
whatever it gives you a little bit I
thought well I feel free
uh I'll drink one of these to feel free
instead of instead of the Manhattan at
night just to have something you know to
well that is what that was the guy who
created feel free was um a recovering
alcoholic who wanted something that he
could drink socially yeah it wasn't bad
for him but that made him feel something
yes yeah so that was the whole purpose
of it so I I I I felt free and uh and
decided to stop drinking the Manhattan
tonight and then
um I enjoyed it I enjoyed it it was fine
but I didn't feel better
and so then I thought well what if I
just have a second feel free now you're
not supposed to do that no you're not
that's exceeding the uh that's two free
that's two that's two free you're
exceeding the recommended you're
doubling the recommended dosage which of
course that's never going to lead to
anything so I stopped doing that but
then I I last week started drinking the
Manhattan again now I'm happy now I'm
happy because I'm drinking in Manhattan
but I didn't take away the feel free
I feel free enough to have a Manhattan I
feel almost in that stage that was that
I was in I don't know 12 years 15 years
ago where uh I was smoking very heavily
and then decided okay I'm gonna quit
smoking but how many years ago did you
say more than that buddy really 20 years
ago yeah I think 20 years ago well
that's look at that 20. that's good
that's good news to have I've been I've
been smoke-free for I felt free from
smoke for 20 years but I would chew the
nicotine gum instead and I choose so
much nicotine gum it's great and that
was great I loved it but then one night
I was out probably with you and I was
like well I'll just have a cigarette so
then I had a cigarette and then I
realized I was smoking at night and then
just chewing the gum all day long and
now I was doing the nicotine gum and the
cigarettes yeah and then I had to stop
it all so that's kind of where I'm at
right now where I'm I'm drinking the I'm
drinking the feel for well first of all
I'm starting the day with a five hours
of energy a Five Hour Energy one of
those every day every day
I've never tried one because you're not
adventurous when I drink I am
adventurous I'm in fried bike Adventure
I like mystery like Discovery I you
handed me a feel free that you were not
adventurous but you gave him the feel
for it exactly he's like hey try this I
was like I opened a whole new realm for
him by the way that happened here fine
Adventure that that happened here you
said you should drink this oh yeah I was
like oh okay it was out I drink it I'm
like oh that that tastes bad and you did
you drink the whole thing by the way
they're this big did you drink the whole
thing and I was like what the [__] are
you talking about you said drink it and
then you turned your head and when you
turned back around I drank it oh and you
were high as a for a while I was like
well it was just a strange feeling it
felt like uh I felt like you were high
well the first time yeah especially the
first time you were really only supposed
to drink half a bottle and some people
that that really is one dose one dose is
half a bottle and then you can take a
second dose later should you so choose
right and drink the second half of the
bottle but uh you just down the hole But
the bottles just to be clear so it's
tiny but it's this big that's what two
ounces yeah maybe so anyway yeah I'm I'm
uh I I don't drink the coffee I do the
five hours of energy solely because it
doesn't hurt my stomach I'm drinking one
of those I'm drinking one of those a day
you've had so many thousands of hours of
energy buddy yesterday but yesterday I
had 10 hours of energy wow what do you
mean I got up early I did my five hours
of energy yeah so that's not enough
energy I said I need 10 hours of energy
five hours later you've spoken about
about six five six hours later you
needed more I I needed I I had a long
day of work yesterday yeah and I had to
I needed I needed to push through and I
see what everybody has their afternoon
tea or coffee now how did the second one
make you feel did it did it do sometimes
I have the afternoon coffee and it's
just no good like it just
it makes me more tired or something it
like it just doesn't like my body just
rejects it no no not me no your body
will have to be back off but then it's
it's hard it definitely makes it harder
to sleep at night oh yeah heads to
Manhattan sure
it's a really good system I think
I gotta get the energy yeah you know
what I mean like where you get up you
get down and then eventually you stay
there
but the studio gets you down well but
listen I'm also I'm coupling that with
this green juice
this is just green vegetable juice right
okay and then I work out you know I work
out pretty hard which means my heart's
probably going to explode at some point
now you know that the vegetables they're
fighting you too right you know the
vegetables they've got their own defense
mechanisms and they they they're
difficult to break down and uh so
everything's killing us guys everything
are you telling me that not to drink
vegetables now I'm telling you not to
eat vegetables I'm telling you that
vegetables have things in them that make
them somewhat toxic to us not all most
of them do most of them do this is true
Akin Dennis
[Applause]
I mean the overlaps are really funny
like when when this stuff comes from
something yeah it does yeah
well it smokes for cigarettes and and
suffocate the uh the toxins
where this is new but you always come in
with new new
people have a problem with nightshades
right you know people who are like
allergic I'm allergic to nightshades
whatever yes okay it's become Brady I've
heard Tom Brady say that but he doesn't
he doesn't eat nightshades hey he's
trying to keep his inflammation down
yeah yes exactly but why would eating a
vegetable give you inflammation for all
the same reasons that I'm talking about
so too much of anything basically is not
not a good thing I've got I've come full
circle on the meat thing I mean look we
were told for a long time like you're
not supposed to eat red meat it's bad
for you don't eat red meat get your
cholesterol everybody in the world of
like health and wellness and Longevity
is like no no eat nothing but meat
vegetables are killing you like you can
have some asparagus and some zucchini
that's his thing and he died at like 50s
right yeah but that's because that's
because people were doing that wrong and
and you know he was like eating you know
also didn't he slip and fall and hit his
Factory bacon I think one of those cats
like like died young and people use that
as evidence as to how not to live but I
think he like cracked his [__] head
open on the sidewalk yeah
if it landed on an eggplant to soften
the blood there were some vegetables
around he would have been fine a couple
night shades to land right but you land
on that little piece of chicken it's too
thin it's it's the extremes
is the Glen of extremes because I I do
appreciate and respect how how much time
effort and care you put into doing
research on on whatever it might be so
you're gonna buy a a new you're always
like this you you're going to buy a new
rug and he would do six months of
research
on spool count uh spooky red thread
count and spoiling spoiling methods I
didn't do that but he's I know what
you're saying yes and so uh when it came
to your health uh consumption control
um that you you always just dove in head
first and I appreciate it but yeah I'm a
scientists would grab me this
conversation would grab me and suddenly
a spool account I would be like okay so
Dennis is obsessed with spool count yeah
and has has that count yeah and Drake
out and has been convinced that you guys
have a rug in your apartment with a
certain school count only to find out
that your spool account is like way less
yeah and as a result the mites have
really taken hold yeah and you know
they've built their little houses and
laid their eggs and then once a return
on the rug because the spool counts too
low anyway so Max starts injecting
himself to get his spool count higher
thinking that he's talking about
something else I'm talking about jizz
your personal spool account yeah right
um but go on you you research and well
and then and then this would happen
throughout the the entire run of the
show where Glenn would come in and it
wouldn't be like hey I'm trying buying
this new diet or I'm trying this new
experimental thing it would be it would
come in and be like don't you guys
understand that eating food that's
cooked is killing you
and we would be like oh uh yesterday
again just an example of something not
something I've ever actually said
ish I've never said the cookies no but
like when you were going through the um
the uh the cayenne pepper thing which
we've which we've talked about but you
were very clear about how like
this the things that you guys are doing
are killing you everything you put into
your body is a is a toxin and then you
would come in six months later and be
like everything I said six months ago is
wrong actually no no I would say I'm on
The Cutting Edge
no no
uh I'm on The Cutting Edge I don't
understand I don't know what you're
saying I I don't I'm I'm having trouble
following this basically I'm following
the science right yes right and that's
constantly changing and evolving because
as we know science is a liar sometimes
right so we're constantly learning new
things right the guy who created A.I
didn't know what it was going to become
of course he didn't how could he right
so science is evolving we are evolving
as people right we learn we learn new
information I'm still I'm 47 years old
and I'm still taking in new information
hahaha can you believe it can you
believe it this is what I led with I
appreciate you you're you're always
learning and growing and trying new
things that you come in with such
conviction that that there is no doubt
in my mind that's starving myself when
was the last time I talked to you about
food and diet today
yeah but that's because it came up on
the podcast but like I see do I I don't
I don't preach about what I eat I don't
talk about what I eat with people unless
they ask or if it comes up in a podcast
because it's interesting it's a it's a
good forum to you know talk about like
you know we've got to talk about
something right but like I don't go
around telling people I don't talk about
my diet I don't talk about what I eat I
don't talk about my supplements I don't
talk about any of that [__]
now maybe I used to but I don't anymore
okay so get off me
so get off my [__] ball should I
drink that I don't know I don't know I
don't know the jury's out well what
vegetables you can drink it but it's
gonna fight you a little bit look it's
gonna fight yeah exactly well speaking
of all these wonderful products and
getting heated about products yeah let's
talk about kittens home of the original
mittens what is it what is the type oh
it's a Paddy's Pub home of the original
Kitten Mittens Patty's Pub guys this is
season five episode eight now let's just
set this up for us Rob well this is what
happens in the episode okay
um it aired on November 5th 2009 it was
written by Sunny Lee and Patrick Walsh
and directed by Randall Einhorn another
Einhorn when a merchandising convention
Comes to Town the gang tries to develop
marketable products in attempts to build
the Paddy's brand I love this episode
yeah it's very funny I loved it uh I
loved it as well I
I didn't remember a lot of it uh it's
been a while yeah it's been a while
since I watched it it's not what I think
of often
um but it was pretty simple and fun and
good uh yeah I mean there's some iconic
stuff some of the most the most iconic
thing of course the the very first thing
the kitten men's commercial
is your cat making too much noise all
the time is your cat constantly stopping
around driving you crazy
is your cat clawing at your furnitures
there's no answer you're so stupid there
is Kitten Mittens
finally there's an elegant comfortable
Mitten for cats
I couldn't hear anything I remember
shooting that commercial and and
laughing at how funny the cat is walking
was but I remember like everyone like
cracking up because you know oftentimes
the video uh monitors for the scene are
just behind the
a fake wall it's a set right so you guys
were in the other room I remember like
Randall like laughing out loud and you
guys laughing
but I remember doing it not thinking it
was that funny doing it just being a
weird thing right when you're doing
something you're like I don't even and
everyone's laughing I don't even know
why it's yeah funny yeah yeah yeah
normally I think everything's funny and
I'm laughing as well yeah sure yeah a
little bit there too but uh well you and
I have always really enjoyed
acting bad acting is always really
really really fun I think that was and
like I know that's what I was enjoying
about it too is like you're you're
really bad inflections yeah you know
what I mean like pronouncing it like
just just the weird musicality yeah
you're wrong like looking at your own
hand and you know like you could just
like be doing a hand and then realizing
yeah is that okay to do but uh yeah and
then
like your whole storyline I'd kind of
Forgotten a lot of it dude the thong
thing yeah so funny Patty's thong is so
funny yeah and disturbing and great it's
really disturbing yeah but that does
feel like the rationale the characters
I'm gonna I'm gonna buy I'm gonna we're
gonna sell women's underwear but we're
not gonna sell them to women we're gonna
sell them to men who are going to buy
them for their ladies so visual
stimulant yes yeah it's not for the
ladies it's for the man
yeah and then of course Brian Unger who
plays the lawyer who we should have on
the on this podcast yeah we really
should he is so we should ask yeah he's
so good and it's so funny but you know I
was watching him being like I don't know
what to talk about with this episode
because I don't remember any sort of
like funny things let's talk about the
dicktails I can't remember how the dick
towel thing in particular I remember
okay yeah my my mother came out to visit
my two mothers and uh we we were living
um not how I expected that story to
start yeah yeah we well we were we were
down in Venice Beach and you know when
you walk along Venice Beach or any Beach
town really I'm sure you could find this
in Myrtle Beach or Virginia Beach
um they have those stores with funny
t-shirts yeah yeah and like all big
towns right yeah Venice got tons of that
and I remember seeing most Beach times
yesterday and so I just always remember
seeing those ridiculous ones with the
bikinis and I don't I'd always be like
who thinks that's funny like who would
ever buy that and so both my mothers
come out and and I'm back at the house
and they come back from the beach and
they're both wearing them and they're
like and they're like look at this look
at these this is hilarious it's the big
T-shirt with the bikini layout with the
bikini ladies with the large breasts and
my mom would be like look I got big tits
so I'm like yep that's it there it is
there it is yeah and it was and it was
funny I mean it was funny so
um so that we were talking about that
and then we're like how can we do a
version of that in towel form and I
still have the original dicktail that
horny Drew so I was explaining it today
I was explaining like what I was
thinking where one side would be this
and one side would be the other and so
we had to do the math where you folded
it over and then it had to fit perfectly
and David just drew it the first one
just drew it I still have it at my house
myself what do people love more than
anything else in the world
of Comedy they do everybody loves comedy
right so when I'm funny I can do funny
but you got to have functionality with
your comedy okay you can't just go
throwing jokes around willy-nilly oh so
I did one of those you drew a men's
buttocks on a towel yeah you get out of
the shower in the college dorm they got
the butt right people are laughing your
buddies are laughing and then and then
you give them one of these boom
oh that is big that's a big monster dick
that's huge that's the biggest dick
you've ever seen yeah that's really
that's not how you see yourself no
that's funny that is fun that's fun yeah
people are gonna laugh at that that's
just set up what is it for this
oh it's a baby dick yeah we're gonna
sell a million of these well we asked FX
we're like uh can we sell these and
they're like yeah you guys can we can't
touch it that's exactly what happened we
went to FX and said we believe that we
have a merchandising opportunity and
they were like oh cool like what can we
do t-shirts like Patty's t-shirts and
sunny t-shirts and we were like yeah
kind of but what we really want to do is
a towel with two dicks on it yeah and
they were like hmm no so we go to FX and
we say um can we check this out yeah
let's merchandise these towels and they
came back and they said we can't do this
we just can't do it but if you guys want
to we're not going to stop you which we
which we appreciate yeah that was nice
of them and then we worked with our
friends from Suburban Ryan well yes then
then we thought like well okay this is
like we could do a really funny episode
but really what this will be about is
selling dick towels yeah you know what I
mean for us like just making a little
side money right so yes we went one
point that I'd be you know Charlie Day
of the dictal fortune yeah I know I know
I've been perfectly fine with that you
know like your kids in college and you
know there's like what's your dad do uh
he sells dick too he sells dick towels
yeah so we set up the website yeah
dictoword.com and then
um and then we had it crashed
immediately
only on the East Coast when it when it
aired just on the East Coast the whole
site crashed they were not ready for the
traffic which was a bummer because we
don't know exactly how many orders we
got but within the first week do you
remember how many dicks dick tells we
sold no I don't well we didn't make a
ton of money oh yes we did we did pretty
good did we did pretty good we did see
did you pay me once again Charlie just
gets checks and he puts them and they
come in and they just sit on his stack
of checks you know we made a lot of
money from that a lot of money from that
we sold 50 000 dick towels
50 000 within like three weeks do you
think if we went on like Shark Tank and
we pitched each one of those products
which one do you think that they would
want to invest in the pen
the egg the dick towel the shotgun
the thong am I forgetting one is there
another one I don't know do you guys
watch that show I can't make it I can't
make I cannot figure out their thought
process on that show somebody will come
in with like the most amazing product
and they're like I just don't see it I
don't get it the thought process is what
they say this is stupid give you 100
Grand and own like 50 of your company
and people are like oh that's a good
idea yes but I can't with the thought
process I'm what I mean when I say I
can't figure out the thought process I
can't figure out what it is what they're
looking that qualifies as something that
they've like they will they will be like
asking which product do you think would
be well the most successful product was
the dick towel so I think the one that
they would pick would probably be egg
because they're like yeah well nobody's
going to want to buy you know that's the
funny thing about businesses like where
some guy goes in or gal makes a fortune
on something that you know you just
don't see right like that's the totally
having the vision to see the thing
that's what that's what makes somebody
the great business person yeah me not me
I want to do the jokes I want to do that
you know I don't want to sell the eggs
but I'll sell eggs
[Music]
this episode was brought to you by
bluetooth you know the chewable tablet
that gets your flag flying at full mast
Lucha is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra you know Cialis uh Levitra
um but in chewable tablets and look at a
fraction of the cost yeah total and you
can pop one of their tablets at any time
you know a day or night so you can plan
ahead or or just be ready when the
opportunity arises the process is is
simple you sign up at bluechoo.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved your prescription comes
straight to your door yeah yeah yeah
right within days in a very cool very
very discreet by the way package if you
don't want anyone to know it's very
discreet okay that's helpful yeah and
you know what else is great it's all
done online you know so you know no no
awkward visits with your doctor no
awkward exams no announcements over the
loudspeaker like this guy here you know
he's he he wants an erection you know
none of that none of that Bluetooth
wants to help you have better sex
discover your options at bluechew.com
chew it and do it and you know what we
actually have a special offer for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use our promo code sunny at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code Sunny to
receive your first month free why would
you do it not for free when you could do
it for free so visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank Bluetooth for
sponsoring the podcast
what do you know it we are supported by
ag1 ag1 is a foundational nutrition
supplement that supports whole body
health
with each scoop you're absorbing get
this absorbing
75 high quality vitamins minerals
probiotics and Whole Food sourced
ingredients I actually lean on Aging
when I'm traveling I I use a single
serving age you want travel pack to help
support my immune system when I'm going
back and forth to Europe and guess what
I'm not getting sick plus it gives me
that little pep in my step you know a
little energy which I love well that's
because ag-1 is a made with a science
driven formula and they're uh they're
constantly testing it and updating it
you know they know how to build your
health from the from the foundation up
because you know what your house I'm a
house your house we're all a bunch of
homes that need a strong Foundation to
stand on don't be a house of cards be a
house of Steel yeah let's be honest this
stuff just tastes good right you guys
like the taste yeah I like the taste
yeah that's right it doesn't doesn't
taste like a foundational supplement
like you would normally get you know I
mean it's subtly sweet and delicious
yeah yeah it's like it's like having the
basement and foundation with like a
gourmet kitchen inside yeah yeah it's a
lot like that yeah I started taking ag1
every single day not only because I
wanted to consolidate my supplement
regimen but because I wanted to shore up
my gut health gotta get that good got to
clean the pipes got to keep the pipes
nice and clean you know what I'm saying
you gotta so if you want to take
ownership over your health try ag1 and
get free one year supply of vitamin D
and five free ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase go to
drinkag1.com Sunny that's drink ag1.com
Sunny check it out
[Music]
I love when we talked about how
I mentioned that the technology just
isn't there to Propel water from a gun
right right well they figured out with
water pistols yeah yeah or water guns
yeah it doesn't you can't feel the St
you want to feel the steam in your mouth
one of my favorite bits is is the uh
eating of the contract
um yes it is very very funny your the
face that you're making this the the the
self-satisfaction
of having solved the problem in that
first scene and US of course you know
realizing that you've also solved the
problem and then of course at the end
same thing and then you're still chewing
on it
excuse me sir can I see these supposed
documents that you have yes
um in fact I happen to have that right
here
[Applause]
you know fortunately I made hundreds of
copies of that
so uh why don't y'all have just a nice
day how was the taste of the contract
and of course you never actually
swallowed one right I never never
swallowed it but I also don't remember
there ever being prop paper I think it
was just a piece of paper that I ate
yeah it doesn't taste like anything it's
just paper just paper rock paper is
paper yeah that's right it doesn't have
any sort of rice based paper yeah I
don't know like maybe you can actually
eat it yeah it seems that seems like
something that a real show would have
wouldn't it I don't know how many real
shows have people eating contracts
just like some lawyer show where it's
like well I solved another one
real show we had a lot of we had a lot
of non-speaking featured actors that
were not background in in the episode
and one of which I remember I distinctly
remember being in in the scene uh the
young woman that that Frank brings in
Brenda yeah and where everybody's
talking and she doesn't say anything and
I I remember her saying like I think I
should say something here and our
response wasn't no you shouldn't it was
we can't afford it yeah we can't afford
it yeah we can't pay you the extra that
it costs and for people who don't know
this like the second character has a
line you their their pay goes way way
way up and I I remember being like she
should say something this is ridiculous
yeah they're just dead silence it wasn't
that we it wasn't even that we couldn't
afford it it was that we hadn't budgeted
for it yes so we couldn't afford
everybody
yeah you can't do it and we already had
guest cast speaking guest cast in the
show Brian yeah the guy we were young
enough to not know that we could be like
yeah let's just do it oh now we would do
it yeah yeah just go ahead say something
and then we'll figure out where to save
the money somewhere else yeah the other
woman who Dee and I bring in to uh and
she plays a prostitute and it's our form
of payment he was on a reality show with
like Axel Rose called like love is a
love is a rose or love is an axel
For the Love of an action I don't know
yeah what the show was called it was
like a VH1 real yeah that's right yeah I
forgot about that
um I don't remember what it was though
it was it was some kind of a dating show
though yeah I think he was like
choosing who to
be his next wife I don't know I don't
know what it was weird that seems I
heard that Axel Rose was it I was maybe
not Axel Rose maybe maybe it was oh no
there was like Michaels Brett Michaels
yeah yeah yeah well he did do he did
have a reality show it's like give me
give me love that's what it was I think
that's what it was
um I don't know
maybe you're thinking that wait did they
sing Every Rose Has Its Thorn is that
Brett Michael uh it's not poison yeah is
that Brett Michaels yeah that's that
might have been that's what you were
thinking that's that's why you were
thinking Axel Rose because he sings that
song every rose has its horn yeah rose
rock stars I don't know Glam Rock but
Axl Rose is in a different category I
mean I know what you mean in terms of
course the file system in your brain I
get why you put Bret Michaels and Axl
Rose in the same category that does make
sense but they're drastically different
yes it's performance of course yes um
but lots of Rose top five voices in the
history of rock and roll yes yes top
five voices in the history of rock and
roll
top 10 top 10 in the top 10.
so distinct when you hear his voice like
if you hear Brett Michael sing yeah he's
got a good friend of all rock and roll
well what's the criteria are you saying
like no he rocks
wow
wow he's loud he's consistent but you
know when you hear his voice you know
it's him it's just it's distinct okay
but it's not in the way that like um by
the way like like Bob Dylan has a
distinct voice but you wouldn't say you
wouldn't say yeah yeah it's like a group
I mean a traditionally great voice right
as in like he can't hit the notes and he
sometimes yeah he's singing straight and
that is no syncretic delivery is what
makes him also what makes him great but
you wouldn't classify that as like a
traditionally great voice yes
like range and ability you mean like
yeah I mean yes very impressive voice
sure if that's what it's that's the
criteria yeah sir
yeah certainly when it comes to like
rock and roll yeah like like who else is
up there this is this I think this is my
podcast James Brown is talking like
singers period or are we talking about
rock and rolling r b which I guess you
could fit into the same category that
[__] is a rock and roll man okay okay
okay yeah no he was it was incredible I
mean like Aretha Franklin you wouldn't
call that women are just or just the
dudes oh okay okay all right yeah listen
um and then I think Axel Rose gets
bumped out but if we want to go just
okay let's go Matt let's go that's my
favorite my favorite Rock vocalist
though is um uh Ann uh oh God what's her
name from heart
the vocalist from heart okay I think she
is the most incredible Rock vocalist of
all time personally I think her voice is
unbelievable have you ever heard her do
like Zeppelin songs
it's way better than Robert Plant I'm
sorry she [__] slays Zeppelin now I
like are you adding into the mix like
Mariah Carey and like no that's pop
that's pop that's not right I think it
just voices that Voices That Rock
Voices That Rock well I got listen I
mean I also got a rock from the hardcore
well are we just saying just rock and
rolls Wilson post like 90s it's done I
thought this would be fun but it is fun
it's too much it's too big academies
even people know what he fucking's ever
heard of Ann Wilson nobody's ever heard
of the animals of course I've heard
heart it's just yeah you can see you can
read the comments now yeah you should
have said that I listen yeah I mean well
I'm I got a shout out to my boy Mike
Patton
Tomahawk is a Mike Patton project uh he
is widely considered no listen in rock
circles he is widely considered to be
one of like probably the top three
greatest rock vocalists of all time
easily and by many number one hands down
hands down in rock circles
all right ask people in the business
like like the general public like a lot
of people don't really appreciate or
understand what it is that he's doing
but if you're in the business you can
you can see what he's doing and be like
what I was looking for was like a robust
conversation that everybody could jump
into where you're like who's the best
basketball player of all time it would
be like LeBron James Michael Jordan
Larry Bird and you're like Sam Bowie is
one of the most well respected Crystal
Pete Maravich exactly I'm not going to
dispute it but at the same time that's
the thing man you know you think it
stops yeah
at least there's a metric with sports
right well this person has the most
championships or points like with music
because like I listen to Axel Rosen I
find it kind of grating you know what I
mean but I get it I understand why you
say that I understand why people like it
but I I don't see as big of a
distinction between Guns and Roses now
I'm gonna get [__] crucified for this
and I know this but that's okay
I don't see as big of a distinction
between guns and roses and like poison
as some people do to me it's kind of
no no that's not true no there's they're
definitely better they're definitely
much much better in my opinion but
I don't know it's just it's still not my
thing well where I made the overlap was
just in fashion look and feel you know I
mean we're going the same they're
shopping at the same place okay they
were for a long period of time yes
they're getting their hair done by the
same dude and
you know what I mean and they're they're
all having sexual relations with the
same women yes yes right across
around the country we're talking about
Brett Michaels and Axl Rose sure if
you're a member of Motley Crue and a
member of poison and a member of GNR
when you would travel around the world
you would run into the same group of
yeah like if you take those two dudes I
don't I don't know this to be true
I'm not saying it isn't I'm not just
filming it I don't know what I'm saying
what I'm saying no I'm not you're saying
19 uh late 1980s Pam Anderson was was
hanging around both concerts potentially
you're going on a world tour and you're
in it you're in a Glam band a glam rock
band and you're going to Detroit and
you're going to Saskatchewan and you're
going to Germany and the people that are
buying the tickets to go to those
together concerts and they're the ones
that are trying to get backstage they're
the same are the same are the same okay
I got you you're saying the people that
are going to the poison concerts the
same people that are going to The Motley
Crew concerts and people going to GNR
I'm saying that there was syphilis was
introduced into the group and it was
passed by the same people around it
started with one there was a patient
zero sure and it could have been a
member of the crew syphilis Susie let's
call it you went to the groupie I went
to one of the one of the band members
yeah yeah yeah okay well
[Laughter]
on Sports Talk Radio like that's all
they do they have a whole business
that's revolved around just talking
about like who's the best give us your
top five I don't want to anymore oh yeah
Glam Rock voices why can't we do that
Stephen Tyler but why can't we bring
Steven Tyler's got one of the great one
of the greatest he's got a great view of
course you can it's just that nobody
knows I mean yes nobody likes the song
Barracuda
what the [__] you talking about
we use the heart song Alone on the show
all the time yeah I think she's one of
the greatest if I think she's one of the
greatest rock vocalists of all time
I think she blows all those people that
you named out of the [__] water she's
incredible okay and and look at the
comments look at the comments because
the only people that are going to
comment are people that actually
understand no music and listen to a lot
of music and we'll look at this and go
finally somebody's recognizing Ann
Wilson those are the comments it's not
going to be like Ed Wilson and Wilson's
not as good as [__] Axel Rose none of
the comments will say that Axel Rose is
better than Ann Wilson I'm gonna go out
right now and say I will not read the
comments on this because they will be
exhausting yeah
exhausting I know that's part of that
yes but see I do find this to be an
interesting conversation the same person
that would say Ann Wilson would say Tim
Duncan is the greatest basketball player
of all time and you could go because
well he's consistent he but it's not a
part of the fun fight I mean it's in his
name
um I would say
it's a terrible joke um I but I would
say that amongst amongst like sports
nerds that is the conversation if you're
gonna have a conversation with somebody
who's a music nerd like me you you're
gonna get you're gonna get CR you're not
gonna get like oh you know who's the
greatest [__] vocalist of all time is
like the the lead singer of I can't even
think of like five minutes then
sometimes you got to be like but yeah
Coldplay like Christmas play into the
metric right like because that's a
that's a part of it right let's say
you're naming the greatest band of all
time right and someone says the Beatles
right and you're like no way dude Mr
Bungle is way better than the Beatles
right well right he he got at some point
you have to take six they are by the way
but God uh
uh no at some point you have to take
success into the equation right it's got
to play in it's I don't know it's a good
I don't know oh it's all subjective
right it's also subjective yeah that's
the thing that's and again like you were
saying with sports like you can you can
quantify like the numbers
maybe some Legend of like street
basketball right who like exactly that's
the point make a hoop from everywhere
but but you can't equate you can't say
the pattern of Michael Michael Jordan
but yeah because you can't equate that
guy to Ann Wilson of heart you know what
I mean like that band was huge
the band was huge they weren't as big as
Guns and Roses but they were huge like
in other words she's not like some I
hear you maybe it's almost about when
when it was introduced meaning like it
would be I just keep bringing back to
sports because this is what people do in
Sports Talk Radio and people find it
fascinating you're talking about like
Michael Jordan you're talking about
LeBron James you're talking about Larry
Bird you're talking about Will
Chamberlain or if you were talking about
like well no I mean in the beginning of
the conversation and then someone comes
in and says yes but you're not thinking
about Tim Duncan the most consistent
player of all time right and then you
get into that part of the conversation
but there's no way in
if you stop from my perspective if you
stymie it from the very beginning by
being like you're all you're thinking
about it all wrong but we haven't even
gotten to that attention in the room
today yeah but I mean me because I I
used to free this morning maybe that's
part of the problem
you're not free enough to take in the
information these are the hard questions
these are the things that the listener
at home must know you know is Mr Bungle
better than the Beatles you know they're
so different they're so they're so
different of course compare yeah in the
same yes in the same for the same reason
you could say Steph Curry might not be
the the greatest basketball player of
all time but he's the greatest
three-point shooter of all time no doubt
and then somebody else might say no it's
Reggie Miller yeah yeah yeah yeah but
that there's a whole
multi-billion Dollar business based on
people just fighting about this kind of
stuff and maybe we're not maybe we're
just not that but no it's not
interesting thing but it is it is
interesting to me that like fight now
you were talking about rock vocalists
and I threw in a name I threw somebody's
hat in the ring and then you accused me
of stymieing the conversation
yes like I went with what you were
saying like I you know what I mean he's
just saying I mean I understand what do
you understand the point I mean I
understand the point you're making I
Just Disagree provocative to throw a
name in who's not a household name in
the as the second person but because she
is a household name is what I'm saying
she is a household name if you I
couldn't even think of her name you
couldn't think of her name yeah I've
heard of the name but that was but if
you asked the entire audience who's the
lead singer of Heart again no offense
she's got way less people would know who
Ann Wilson is than than uh Axel Rose yes
yes
Oh So Satisfied with yourself you make
me sick today
hahaha
just money talk yeah you know what I'm
saying that's a cash register that's
Universal that sound that means money
yep that's the sound of a brand new sale
on Shopify aka the moment someone's
business dream just became a reality and
not only someone's business dream
our business stream that's right Shopify
is the uh Commerce platform it says
revolutionizing millions of businesses
worldwide including ours and whether
you're selling boiled denims fight milk
it simplifies selling online and and in
in person so you can focus successfully
on growing your business it covers every
single sales Channel you know from an
in-person POS system to an all-in-one
e-commerce platform it even lets you
sell across social media marketplaces
like uh like Tick Tock Facebook
Instagram you know all the hits all the
big ones all the all the good ones plus
it's packed with industry leading tools
ready to ignite your growth Shopify
gives you complete control over your
business and brand without having to
learn any new skills in design or code
and thanks to 24 7 help and an extensive
Business course Library Shopify is ready
to support you every step of the way we
here at the Always Sunny podcast use
Shopify we do for all of our podcast and
tour merch it's so easy we could get
silly with marketing and serious with
selling yeah and now it's your turn to
get serious about selling and try
Shopify today sign up for a one dollar
per month trial period at shopify.com
Sunny all lowercase go to shopify.com
Sunny to take your business to the next
level today shopify.com sunny
this is now the second episode where Meg
is not here
I for one have no idea who's supposed to
steer the chat when we're discussing the
episode I I I feel I'm having trouble
keeping on track too and um at what
point do we just go ahead and replace
her no no no no no there is no replacing
bag first off where would we even find
someone to fill her shoes it's
impossible didn't we have luck on
ZipRecruiter when we were looking to
replace that camera operator yeah yes
yes this recruiter was good for that is
that we use zip recruiter for that
that's true zip recruiter is a it's a
hiring platform that uses the most
Cutting Edge matching technology to help
you quickly sift through candidates and
invite the most qualified ones to apply
you know I mean it's look it certainly
worked for the for the camera job but
again that was for a a role with a wide
field of applicants you know
all right you know what I'm with Rob
actually uh there's no way we can find
another Maggie even even without
top-notch zip recruiters there is no
replacing bag that that's fine I'm just
super high on zip recruiter you know
what I mean because it always is giving
are such good candidates for all the
positions that we're looking to fill you
know so if you're listening at home and
you're thinking okay I too am in need of
a great candidate to hire we've got some
advice for you here we really do stop
waiting and start using zip recruiter no
matter what your business is
ZipRecruiter can help you find quality
candidates for all your roles fast and
right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com Sunny yeah here's an
interesting fact actually you guys like
facts I love it okay well did you know
that on average it can take up to 11
weeks to hire a person for a position 11
weeks I mean that's too long four out of
five employers who post on ZipRecruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day how insane is that so speed up your
hiring process with zip recruiter all
right Cy 3.8 million businesses have
come to zip recruiter for their hiring
needs yep just go to this exclusive web
address to try ZipRecruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com
sunny again that's ziprecruiter.com
s-u-n-n-y
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
[Music]
greatest band of all time oh my God
Glenn no heart
it has been established that Glenn
believes that heart I don't think that
heart is anywhere near the singer Mary
Hart Who was the Ann Wilson Ann Wilson
and rice no heart is not one of my
favorite bands I do like a lot of their
stuff but it's not nowhere near not even
in my top 50s
is that hard
and that Fleet Fleetwood Mac I I don't
know the answer is Hanson and here's why
okay
they make great soda too you have to
take age into account uh anyways okay so
Kitten Mittens uh
this episode is dedicated to David zunky
yeah
Ernie the bar fly do you have any
memories of working with him now now
when he popped up in the video
I started uh because you don't really
see it much in the episode until the the
video that you play at the end for at
the convention
and I I was like wait did we shoot this
earlier because in my memory he had he
passed away season three
but I guess I guess yeah yeah so it kind
of threw me for a loop that we cut to
him I think we shot the whole season
with him and then and then he passed
away right and then half of the season
was shot yeah yeah didn't we but we
called him Z
that was his nickname z Oh in real life
yeah in real oh yes yes because of his
last name we have a character named yeah
yeah yeah yes but we called him z
um uh no I just remember him being
overall just a pretty pretty lovely
lovely dude and a total total trip and
and I kind of regret not hearing more
stories from him because he was abducted
by aliens
sure he was
well according to him yeah all right so
he told you this story yes all right
tell the story he was a well was he
probed uh we didn't get into the
specifics of it but he was taken he was
taken uh he was out in the desert and um
and Palm Desert he was out there yeah he
was probably I don't think even the
aliens were waterproof problems yeah
like I love the guy oh man you don't
know what the kind you probe well aliens
now aliens they they don't see things
the way you see them right they may say
him and be like that's a that's what I
want hot is it yes I
probably for you man
I was prominent for you I knew you would
want to see what was in there yeah yeah
I didn't do it for me I probed him for
you
um no he was selling he told he told me
the story and it was one of those things
where you don't know if somebody is
making a joke you know how'd they snatch
him he was out in the desert all he
remembers is seeing uh seeing a lot of
lights and then he was there man he was
there he was and I was like where and he
was like I was with them with them yeah
I was with them well he he didn't say it
was a ship he just said he was in
another it was another okay so let me
tell you what happened
he did as many of us do he went out into
the desert and he had some peyote or he
had some mushrooms or uh you know acid
and uh and then was abducted by aliens
as many of us have been when we're high
on acid or
[__] was abducted by aliens and
that's why he is the way that he is you
know right scrambled he got a little
scrambled up in there up in the ship and
you know they they brought him back they
sent him back
but when they you know he was never the
same yeah like it just the parts didn't
add back up again that is something that
also was a result of uh taking high
amounts of LSD as well
you know you come back you're never the
same no you're not yeah yeah he said it
was all about overall a positive
experience he didn't remember a lot of
it but he was there and uh he said but
and and now he's back do you guys know
anybody personally who claims to have
been abducted by aliens and and can
speak other than him other than you know
yeah
no I don't but
I mean I'm not ruling it out
seems absurd to totally rule it out oh
it's totally absurd I'm agnostic when it
comes to aliens highly possible I'm
Gonna Roll it out just based on just
based on logic as we understand it now
but but we don't understand [__] that's
the thing right now they're killing us
dude yeah you didn't even know we're
eating vegetables like a bunch of
[__] you didn't even know that I'm
into it I'm into the idea of it I love
it buddy there's some plants out there
that if they're not aliens then I don't
know what is so at what point did you
guys make the transition from or maybe
you haven't I don't know but to to being
afraid of ghosts and not wanting to be
confronted by a ghost to to really
desperate wanting to see one yeah there
are still times at 46 where I lay in bed
and I hear a noise in the house and I
know it's not some Intruder and I'm
hoping to God I go down there
you want a spirit to be rummaging around
the ghost or the alien I think the I I
say Alien
aliens you know what I'm realizing can I
just stop down for one second I'm
realizing we need Meg here
we need Meg here so bad
um I mean I don't know how much there is
to even really say about this episode I
mean that's it you know we did we know
that much stuff it was funny yeah you
know that's weird like I like to do
anything with the camera we didn't have
a guest star that we haven't discussed
like
uh there was there was one joke in the
episode that I would also like to bring
up and I remember thinking was really
really funny when we were shooting it
was the uh you spying spying on the on
the uh trying to spy on the lawyer but
catching a woman yeah
that lawyer or secretary no I don't
don't know why you think we're going to
catch him having an affair I mean the
guy's wife is really hot no she's not
and also why does he turn her picture
away from him so he doesn't have to look
at her face why are we in the Shady
Motel where we saw him go in I'm telling
you he's he's banging that secretary it
just doesn't add up she's a an
attractive lady it's not attractive oh
my God what the woman in the room right
next to him she just hit an entire
sleeve of Chips Ahoy Charlie could you
focus on the lawyer's room please we're
not here to Blackmail a lady for eating
too many cookies and then she asks if
she is she a a big woman and you said oh
she's she's huge oh yeah yeah she's huge
which I found funny I don't know she's
eating entire sleeves of Chips Ahoy it's
going to catch up to you it must be done
with this okay yeah this is out of
control yeah this is out of control
where's my where is Meg I don't know she
is Humphrey somewhere dude are they on
vacation they're doing a thing I don't
know what they're doing she she told me
she's told me the word
she told you exactly where she's going
and I got what I needed her Humphrey and
she first
okay
uh oh well this one you guys didn't know
that this will Air much after her
birthday somebody sent me a review I
haven't read a review of Sunny I don't
know that they do reviews of Sunny do
they but they say some uh land graph
sent me something and it just made me
feel really good what was it gonna tell
me yeah
because this is just let's end on
something that feel it just feels nice
hey guys season 16 is out this is this
excuse me we worked very hard on this we
worked very hard on this I'm excited for
people to finally uh see what we did I
hope they like it I read this right
before I went to sleep and I thought you
know it's always a it's a mixed bag you
don't want to look for too much external
validation but when you get it you know
it's nice it's nice it is nice quote
it's truly remarkable that after 16
Seasons not only does It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia still remain hilarious
and weird but that it never feels like
it's just going through the motions
Despite All This Time It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia remains one of the
funniest strangest and most
unpredictable shows even after 18 years
and it's this type of longevity and
Brilliance that will make it go down as
one of the Great sitcoms of all time
I'll take that any day who wrote that my
mom
my mom my mommy
foreign
[Applause]